what does the early sign are what early
signs do you see
of virtual meetings resulting in real
cash
i think they will so uh so you know the
guidance that we got so we've talked we
talked to a set of
prestigious vc funds you know in
preparation for our demo day
and the guidance that we got was that
they're all most of them are doing
um i mean all of them right now
obviously doing virtual meetings
they like to do socially distance
meetings before they write their
check but we've seen people write checks
without ever actually having met
there's a strong to date it's been if
you've had a previous
relationship with that fund or they know
you that's a huge
bonus but i don't think i actually think
that it's going to become a lot more
meritocratic
the ultimate issue is that all these
funds especially if you look at the dry
powder funds the funds
there's been a lot of dried powder that
was raised in the last two years that's
not committed
they need to deploy capital or other
unless that you know they have to worry
about their irs so
they still need to write checks and the
the the reality is is that it's too
cumbersome to try to meet with founders
so
you need to set these meetings up and
you need to drive things um
virtually so if they're not getting the
read on the founder they're not getting
the charisma of the founder
and that sort of situation in person
what do you think they're making their
decisions on so they've removed that
high touch the feeling in the room they
get
what are they looking at to replace that
in their decision making stack these
downstream investors
well i do think that all investors have
different sticks and they're not a
monolithic group so there are some
investors that pride themselves on
betting on people and teams and i think
those investors will probably um invest
closer to people that they know or that
they're connected to they can validate
them in some way
and so i think there are you know you
you need to try to find a proxy to get
that investor to trust you
i think other investors actually are
just being much more meritocratic about
doing customer diligence like they
should looking at the product
looking at the data and making decisions
based on that
um i do think valuations are going down
by twenty percent
to um a third um uh and
but which puts us at double reality
probably in all cases
i mean here in the valley so an example
of that might be a 15 million
valuation last year goes down to what 12
or 10.
yeah i would say 10. and so it depends
on the cu and all again every company is
different sure there's outliers
but but i i would but my main point here
is i don't think investors are not
investing i think they're
they're correcting for that risk by
adjusting valuations
yeah and um and i um
i do think that if you're in a if you're
in a market which is
a which is where where you're getting um
wins in your sales because of covid so
collaboration cloud
ecom or e-commerce digital health then
um
i think there are investors that are
moving even more quickly so
how do you deal with competitive
companies
coming to the accelerator you have some
breakout success
doing quantum computing another person
comes in and says i want to build a
company
that defeats that company we have a
better model do you not
invest or do you invest and the founders
of that company understand
that you're an accelerator and you're
going to invest across a wide range of
companies
we our rule is is that we will not
invest in a competitor
within the class that we admit or within
one class after or before that
company that we admit so we keep a
one-class buffer
so that um the because the the biggest
thing that we're building is a trusted
space
both both physically and virtually and
and so we don't want to compromise that
um and and and and and the reality is
that
you know companies pivot all the time so
even if we admit somebody that doesn't
look like they're competitive they may
end up pivoting into that space
and it's been it's i should say it's
been a big boon for most of our alums so
you know rigetti is a is a i think a
fairly famous
quantum computing company that's
graduated from alchemist we also have
had now this ecosystem of other quantum
computings like qc ware
and others that will benefit rigetti so
and launch darkly i think is going to
also have a bunch of great devops
companies that will
come from alchemists that will benefit
launch darkly yeah this is something
that outsiders don't understand
um as the sequoia folks said no conflict
no interest like
usually these things seem a little
conflicted but even that's okay because
the big company might wind up acquiring
the small one so if i invest in a
company
that is working on sleep but i'm also an
investor in com
i bet you com feels pretty good about
that at least they
know that if they were going to acquire
that company they would have somebody
who could say do a proper introduction
right
yeah no that's exactly right and it's
amazing how
in my experience that i understand that
founders have this fear of competition
in general i think it's better to jump
into situations where there's a lot of
people within your ecosystem that could
be relevant
at dfj we three times fun i know we keep
going back to the fj but there are three
times we funded
competitors not intentionally they
became competitors but all three times
both of the companies
um did well they so yeah in any space
there's going to be usually three
winners there's if there's a market that
is ripe for a venture opportunity
there'll be one winner that'll be the
outlier that nobody can acquire that'll
go public
and then the other two will get acquired
by the incumbents in the space that need
to have a strategy there
so in general i would not worry i know
it's easy for me to say this and there
are exceptions
but founders don't worry too much about
competition worry about learning and the
pace of your development